you mentioned that you saw in the main
actress which is a royalty hightower
yeah hi Stoney when you auditioned her
you saw something in her face that was
the ability to listen yeah I find that
interesting why was that important for
her character royalty is an amazing
listener and it's she's not just
listening to me as a director she's also
listening to her fellow performers and
to herself she seems to be always
processing always very active as a
listener and Tony is a really
challenging part in the script we
already knew she was gonna be carrying
almost every single frame of the film
and as an actor I think we were really
looking for someone who was able to
reflect the world on her face and to
dance with her face in a way so the fact
that she's engaged naturally as a person
and really actively listening I think
was the first step to saying yeah I
think I think she can be Tony and she
exceeded all expectations she's just a
generous collaborator and performer what
were the conversations like on set with
royal with royalty yeah we talked about
a lot of things a lot of it was very
physical we would do I started wearing
basically gym clothes to set every day
because it was like we would joke
sometimes we were making a
feature-length workout video is just so
active and we would do sprints and we
would we would chat and we would do
dance exercises to kind of get into
character and start to embody these
movements but we were also talking about
really subtle things like being in a
daydream or being in haze or kind of
what it was like to remember what she
was thinking about and playing around
with very you know lip placement eye
placement because a lot of the time it's
just her face in the frame so it was all
kind of microexpression coaching and was
really fun yeah in terms of working with
the camera what what did you guide
royalty on working with the camera with
the camera I think it was always telling
her that small movements
okay I think as a dancer often your
audience is very far away so the
movements that you're doing as a
performer need to be bigger because
someone in the back of a auditorium or
the back of a gymnasium needs to be able
to see those expressions they're very
big and letting her know that the
audience is only a few inches away so
you can everything we could make smaller
and focused and more minut and I think
that that was something that we explored
kind of bringing down the performance
and breaking it down into smaller beats
you